in this course I will show you how to
identify and fix WordPress performance
issues for good and much of what I teach
about performance applies to
non-wordpress websites as well so there
will be something for everyone my name
is Bo Karens I've created popular
courses about many topics including
WordPress python JavaScript and more now
I'm going to teach you how to improve
the performance of your website
in Motion Hosting provided a grant to
make this course possible they provide
securely reliable web hosting but you
don't need to use their hosting to
implement the tips I share in this
course in Motion Hosting has also made a
tier 3 VPS with WordPress installed
available as a free one-month trial for
anyone following along with this course
at home
here are the top steps you can take
right now to get immediate results we'll
be covering all of these in this course
setting your performance goals
understanding a website request DNS
configuration and cdns server
configuration and tuning for WordPress
caching techniques and optimizing the
WordPress application monitoring and
adjusting website performance is a
critical factor in the success of any
website and optimizing your website for
Speed should be a top priority this
course is an invaluable resource for
anyone looking to optimize their
website's performance and gain a
Competitive Edge in the Online
Marketplace by following the Practical
advice and best practices outlined in
this course you can improve your
website's performance and provide your
users with a fast efficient and
enjoyable online experience
first let's talk about studying your
performance goals determining goals for
optimizing website Speed and Performance
is critical to achieving desired
outcomes here are some steps to help you
establish clear goals and objectives
Define your purpose
start by understanding why you want to
optimize your site's Speed and
Performance is it to enhance user
experience reduce bounce rates improve
conversion rates or achieve better
search engine rankings clarifying your
purpose will guide your goal setting
process
analyze current performance use tools
like Google Lighthouse Google page speed
insights Google search console or web
page test to evaluate your website's
current Speed and Performance identify
areas where improvements are needed such
as slow loading times excessive page
weight or high server response times
these insights will help you prioritize
and set specific goals
prioritize metrics determine which
performance metrics are most important
for your website common metrics includes
page load time time to First byte render
start time and interactive time line
these metrics with your purpose to
identify the most critical areas for
improvement
set measurable targets establish
specific measurable achievable relevant
and time-bound goals or smart goals for
example set a goal to reduce page load
Time by 30 percent within three months
or achieve a ttfb of under 20
milliseconds
clear targets will provide a benchmark
for progress and help you stay focused
consider user expectations
understand your target audience's
expectations and browsing Behavior
different websites may require different
levels of optimization based on their
user base consider factors like device
usage Mobile versus desktop geographic
location and connection speeds to tailor
your goals accordingly
break it down divide your optimization
goals into smaller actionable tasks for
instance optimize image sizes minifying
CSS and JavaScript leveraging browser
caching or implementing a Content
delivery Network breaking down goals
into manageable steps makes them more
achievable and allows for incremental
improvements
Monitor and iterate
regularly monitor your website's
performance using performance monitoring
tools or website analytics track
progress toward your goals and identify
areas that need further optimization
continuously iterate your strategies to
adapt to changing Technologies and user
expectations
by following these steps you can
establish well-defined goals for
optimizing your website Speed and
Performance remember the goal should a
lot be aligned with your website's
purpose be measurable and adaptable to
evolving needs before I talk more about
how to optimize websites let's look at
an unoptimized site
we'll see how the site performs now and
throughout the course we'll optimize the
site then we'll see how it performs at
the end
so here's a site that's already set up
on in motion Central this is a WordPress
site and here's actually the preview of
the site the Sprout invoices so this is
the the settings you get when you have
your WordPress site hosted On In Motion
Central you have the preview of the site
you get your site stats the URL you can
also manage the server from here and you
can do so for the plugin themes and we
have a whole section of optimization
that we'll be talking more about later
and you can also access the wp the
WordPress admin page right from here
so the website is going to look like
this
and now let's check out the performance
first of all I've turned off this plugin
so it's not going to have any just
normal optimization and we'll talk more
about this plugin later
now I'm at the page speed insights uh
website the php.web.dev
this is from Google and it helps you
check the performance of your website
so I'm just going to get my URL here
and analyze
so if we scroll down we can see the
performance is only in the 47th
percentile though we do have some better
scores in these other areas 100th
percentile accessibility so if we scroll
down even further we can see what were
the the bad things so anything red is is
the something that's a low performance
first contentful paint largest
contentful paint total blocking time
speed index and we'll actually be
talking about all of these things a
little more later so if you scroll down
we can get more details and it's showing
a lot of things that could be improved
these are all the different
opportunities and it's showing how we
can improve the site and so this is kind
of a good starting point for any website
you just go to this page feed insights
and it will give you some ideas on how
to improve the site now throughout the
rest of this course we'll be going
through a lot of these things in more
detail the mobile score is a little
different than the desktop score because
because it's emulating a mobile device
and the network speeds so on desktop the
performance is a little better we're at
still not in the green range which is
what we would want but that is a little
better but you want to design all of
your websites so they have good
performance both on desktop and mobile
but again you can see all these these
things that you can improve on
now let's talk about performance testing
tools there are many testing tools
available online to gauge your website
performance in this section we want to
get a website to rank better on Google
so we will use Google's tools to achieve
our goals there are also some other
pretty awesome optimization tools such
as GT metrics pingdom and many others
before we explain how to assess your
site prior to optimizing let's go over a
quick outline of how the different
pieces are weighted in the lighthouse
tests the lighthouse score calculator
gives us information at a glance and
even allows you to plug in your own
scores to understand how your overall
page speed scores score is calculated
inside Chrome's developer tools or Dev
tools you can use the code inspector to
get to the open source extension for
Google Lighthouse it's helpful because
it runs tests right within your browser
and it generates a report for you on how
well the website you are looking at
Stacks up for both mobile and desktop
versions this test gives you information
about performance accessibility best
practices and SEO and here's a tip when
performing a test with devtools you want
to use an incognito window or a guest
account as browser extensions typically
interfere with the test and skew the
results page speed insights is an online
tool that tests your site and then
delivers a score for both mobile devices
and desktop computers you'll see a score
and a breakdown of the metrics used to
determine your site performance
PSI that's page speed insights will also
provide a breakdown of the issues
causing any slowdowns to the performance
of your site recommendations are
provided on actions you can take to Pro
to improve performance PSI uses
simulations and real world data when
available to provide its scores
the Chrome user experience report is
also called The Core web vitals metric
this is an aggregate of user experience
metrics that is compiled from actual
users that visit your website over the
last 28 days the data is not
comprehensive however these these users
are limited to people that have opted to
sync their browser history with chrome
and the data is made available by Page
speed insights Google's bigquery Project
and data Studio while it's helpful
information when optimizing your website
for Speed and Performance it's not
representative of everyone's experience
with your site
the page experience report in Google
search console provides you with a
summary of their measurement for your
visitors user experience Google
evaluates these metrics for individual
URLs on your website and will use them
as a ranking signal in search results
this report covers core web vitals
mobile usability and https usage for
every page that you have in Google's
index in order for a page to be counted
in this report's data it must have data
in the core web vitals report
simultaneously we should mention other
tools as well because this is by no
means an exhaustive list in short there
are a ton of professional tools that you
can use to measure your website's
performance such as GT metrics pingdom
web page test and more any tool you use
will guide you with things that need to
be done to improve your website speed
there are many factors that will impact
the score you see on these tests these
variables can range from your location
related to the website activity on your
server Network routes and even the
activity on your local computer
because of these and many other factors
no two tests will show the exact same
results however with a little
persistence you can minimize the impact
that your server and website bring into
the equation simply follow these
suggestions learn about them and
Implement best practices this will
increase the likelihood that your
visitors will have a good user
experience
when testing your website's performance
and putting together your plan of attack
the tool you use will dictate the
metrics used in the audit here are the
top performance indicators to pay
attention to I recommend focusing on
achieving passing green scores on core
web vitals before you move on to the
other performance metrics
so you can just check out this chart
that we have on screen now
the key to success for your website is
to focus on the user experience Google's
core web bibles are a set of metrics
that measure real world user experience
for loading performance interactivity
and visual stability of the page these
metrics are designed to help you
understand how good the user experience
is on your site compared to other sites
on the web
core web vitals are broken down into a
subset of page experience signals that
apply to all websites and should be
measured by website owners the metrics
that make up the core web vitals are
subject to evolve over time as the
signals are not set in stone and are
intended to change as time passes to
continue improving the overall user
experience on the web
page experience signals and core web
vitals are the best signals that
developers have to measure and improve
the quality of the user experience and
they're broken down into the largest
contentful paint first input delay and
cumulative layout shift I'm going to
outline what each signal is and share
some best practices and steps to take to
ensure you improve your website's
performance in relation to each metric
tools that measure core web vitals
consider a page to be passing if it
meets the recommended Target for of 75th
percentile for all three metrics
largest contentful paint measures your
website's loading performance in order
to provide a good user experience for
your visitors your LCP that's largest
contentful paint should occur within 2.5
seconds of the initial page loading the
types of elements that are considered
for largest contentful paint are usually
images or videos it is important to
understand that an element can only be
considered the LCP once it is rendered
and the user can see it this metric is
also tied to the first contentful paint
which measures how long it takes for the
initial Dom content to render but first
contentful paint does not account for
how long it takes the largest and
usually more important content on the
page to render so a large contemple
paint represents a user's perception of
loading experience
and the lighthouse performance score
weighting is 25 what it measures the
point in the page load time when the
Page's largest image or text block is
visible within the Viewpoint how it's
measured Lighthouse extracts LCP data
from Chrome's tracing tool
and is the largest contentful paint a
web core vinyl yes
so what elements are part of the largest
contentful paint well image elements
image elements inside an SVG element
video elements an element with a
background image loaded via the URL
function blockline elements containing
text nodes or other inline level text
elements children and here's how to
define the LCP using Chrome Dev tools
first open the page in Chrome
then navigate to the performance panel
of the dev tools you can use command
opt-in ion Mac or Ctrl shift I on
Windows and Linux then you hover over
the LCP marker in the timing section
and finally the elements that correspond
to LCP is detailed in the related node
field
so what causes poor LCP poor LCP
typically comes from four issues slow
server response time render blocking
JavaScript and CSS resource load times
and client-side rendering now let's talk
about how you can improve LCP the usual
suspect of a poor LCP can be caused by
many things some of the causes can be
slow response times from the server
render blocking JavaScript and CSS slow
resource load times and even client
rendering
slow server response times is the first
thing you should tackle when optimizing
for performance faster server response
will typically impact and improve every
page loading measurement including LCP
if the cause is slow server response
time you need to optimize your server
route users to a nearby CDN cache assets
serve HTML page cache first and
establish third-party connections early
if the cause is render blocking
JavaScript and CSS you want to Minify
the CSS defer non-critical CSS inline
critical CSS Minify minifying compressed
JavaScript files defer unused JavaScript
and minimize unused polyfills
if the cause is resource load times you
want to optimize and compress images
preload important resources compressed
text Styles deliver different assets
based on the network connection and cash
assets using a service worker finally if
the cause is client signed side
rendering you want to minimize critical
JavaScript or use another rendering
strategy
okay first input delay or FID measures a
website's interactivity and focus on
input events from discrete actions like
clicks Taps and key presses when your
website does not respond in a certain
amount of time after a user interaction
users experience this as a lag or slow
down to provide a good user experience
your web pages should have a FID of 100
milliseconds or less
so what this represents is your user's
first impression of your site's
interactivity and responsiveness
it doesn't apply to the lighthouse
performance score what it measures is
the time when a user first interacts
with your site when they click a link to
Tap a button or use a custom JavaScript
power control to the time when the
browser is actually able to respond to
that interaction
how it's measured it requires a real
user and thus cannot be measured in the
lab however the total blocking time
metric is lab measurable and can be used
as a proxy as it correlates well with
fid in the field and also captures
issues that affect interactivity and is
this a web pore vinyl yes
so what causes poor FID the main cause
is heavy JavaScript execution optimizing
how JavaScript parses compiles and
executes on your web page will directly
reduce fid
how to improve it well you can reduce
impact of third-party script execution
reduce JavaScript execution time like by
deferring unused JavaScript or
minimizing unused polyfills can break up
long tasks optimize your page for
interaction Readiness use webworker
minimize main thread work or finally
keep request counts low and transfer
sizes small
also you should note that FID is being
replaced by inp in March of 2024 inp is
interaction to next paint
cumulative layout shift or CLS measures
visual stability a good user experience
is measured as having a CLS of 0.1 or
less this allows the experience to avoid
any surprises for the user but isn't
particularly helpful for page speed it's
more measurement that your website is
following best practices and is a
necessary piece for achieving a high
performance score for your page these
best practices including following
common ux patterns that are optimized
for CLS when your page is loading you
should always be sure to set size
attributes or reserve space specifically
specify the width or height attributes
to create a placeholder for Content this
will help ensure your page does not
Jitter and move for the customer while
they're trying to interact with it your
website should never insert content
above existing content unless a user
interacts and expects the behavior and
you should always use transformation
animations when trans forming the layout
during said interactions so what it
represents the visual stability of a
page instability is defined as
unexpected movement or page content as
the as the user is trying to interact
with the page and it's 15 of the
lighthouse performance score weighting
what it measures it measures the largest
burst of layout shift scores for every
unexpected layout shift that occurs
during the entire lifespan of a page a
layout shift occurs anytime a visual
element changes its position from one
rendered frame to the next
how it's measured to calculate the
layout shift score the browser looks at
the viewport size and the movement of
unstable elements in the viewport
between two rendered frames the layout
shift score is a product of two measures
of that movement the impact fraction and
the distance fraction
and is this a core a web portfolio yes
so let's look at how to see CLS using
Chrome Dev tools
use Dev tools to help debug layout
shifts by leveraging The Experience pane
under the performance panel the summary
view for a layout shift record includes
the cumulative layout shift score as
well as a rectangle overlay showing the
affected regions
what causes poor layout shifts
changes to the position of a Dom element
this is often the result of style sheets
that are loaded late or overwrite
previously declared style or delays in
animation and transition effects also
changes to the dimension of a Dom
element this is often the result of
images ads embeds and iframes without
dimensions
or insertion of or removal of a Dom
element another cause is animations that
trigger layout this is often the result
of insertion of ads and other
third-party embeds insertion of banners
alerts and modals infinite scroll and
other ux patterns that load additional
content above existing content or
finally another cause is actions waiting
for a network response before updating
the Dom
and how you can improve it always set
attributes to images and video elements
or allocate the correct amount of space
for that element while it's loading
also never insert content above existing
content except during an intentional
user interaction and prefer transform
animations to animations of properties
that trigger layout changes finally
preload fonts using the link Rel preload
on the key web fonts and combine Link
rail preload with font display optional
another performance opportunity is first
contentful paint this measures the time
to render the first piece of the Dom
content it represents the amount of time
it takes the browser to render the first
piece of Dom content after a user
navigates to your page images non-white
canvas elements and svgs on your page
are considered Dom element Dom content
this is 10 of the lighthouse performance
score what it measures this is a
user-centric metric for measuring
perceived load speed because it marks
the first point in the page load
timeline where the user can see anything
on the screen
how it's measured the score is a
comparison of your pages first content
for paint time and the first contentful
paint times for real websites Based on
data from the HTTP archive
it is not a web core vital here's some
ways to improve the first contentful
paint
eliminate render blocking resources
Minify CSS remove unused CSS
pre-connect to required Origins reduce
server response times avoid multiple
page redirects
preload key requests avoid enormous
Network payloads serve static assets
with an efficient cash policy avoid an
excessive Dom size minimize critical
request depth
insert text remains visible during web
font load
keep request counts low and transfer
sizes small
another thing to think about is the
speed index the SI this represents the
average time at which visible parts of
the page are displayed it's 10 percent
of the lighthouse performance score
weighting what it measures the speed
index measures how quickly content is
visually displayed during page load
lighthouse first captures a video of the
page loading in the browser and computes
the visual progression between frames
how it's measured the speed index score
is a comparison of your Page's speed
index and the speed in this is of real
websites Based on data from the HTTP
archive it is not a web core vital
here's some things you can do to improve
speed index
minimize main thread work reduce
JavaScript execution time ensure text
remains visible during web font load
eliminate render blocking resources
another thing to think about is the
total blocking time or TBT
this represents the total amount of time
that a page is blocked from responding
to user input such as Mouse clicks
screen taps or keyboard presses it's 30
percent of the lighthouse performance
score weighting what it measures this
measures the time between first
contentful paint and time to Interactive
it is the lab equipment it is the lab
equivalent of first input delay the
field data used in the Chrome user
experience report and Google's page
experience ranking signal
how it's measured the total time in
which the main thread is occupied by
tasks taking more than 50 milliseconds
to complete if a task takes 80
milliseconds to run 30 milliseconds of
that time will be counted toward the TBT
the total blocking time if a task takes
45 milliseconds to run 0 milliseconds
will be added
is total blocking time a web core vital
yes it's the data it's the lab data
equivalent of first input delay
total blocking time measures long tasks
those tasks taking longer than 50
milliseconds when a browser loads your
site there is essentially a single line
queue of scripts waiting to be executed
any input from the user has to go into
that same queue
when the browser can't respond to user
input because other tasks are executing
the user perceives this as lag
essentially long tasks are like that
person at your favorite coffee shop who
takes far too long to order a drink like
someone ordering a two percent vinti
four pump vanilla five pump mocha whole
froth lung tasks are a major source of
bad experiences some things that cause a
TBT on your page are heavy JavaScript
and heavy CSS and that's basically it
here's how to see TBT using Chrome Dev
tools
and how to improve TBT you can break up
long tasks optimize your page for
interaction Readiness use webworker and
reduce JavaScript execution time now
let's talk about time to First byte or
ttfb
this is a foundational metric for
measuring the time between the request
for a resource and when the first byte
of a response begins to arrive it helps
identify when a web server is too slow
to respond to requests
ttfb is the sum of the following
requests phases redirect time server
work or startup time DNS lookup
connection and TLS negotiation and
request up to the point at which the
first byte of the response is arrived
okay
so here are some ways to improve ttfb
hosting web servers with inadequate
infrastructure to handle high traffic
loads web servers with insufficient
memory that can lead to thrashing
unoptimized database tablets sub-optimal
database server configuration avoid
multiple page requests pre-connect to
required Origins for cross-origin
resources submit your origin to the hsts
preload list to eliminate HTTP to https
redirect latency use HTTP 2 or HTTP 3
and use server side generation for
markup instead of SSR where possible and
appropriate minimizing ttfb starts with
choosing a suitable hosting provider
with infrastructure to ensure high
uptime and responsiveness this in
combination with a CDN can help
significantly
in this section we'll discuss how the
speed of a request to a website impacts
overall website performance when a user
makes a request to load a website a
series of processes happen behind the
scenes to deliver the requested content
to the user's browser this process can
be broken down into the following steps
Step 1 DNS lookup the domain name system
is a distributed database that Maps
domain names to IP addresses when user
types a URL into the browser the browser
first sends a request to a DNS server to
look up the IP address of the domain
name
Step 2 connection once the browser has
the IP address of the website it
establishes a connection to the server
hosting the website using the hypertext
transfer protocol or HTTP or the more
secure HTTP s protocol the S stands for
secure
step 3 request after establishing the
connection the browser sends an HTTP
request to the server requesting the
specific web page or resource that the
user wants to access
step 4 processing the server receives a
request and begins to process it this
may involve executing scripts querying
databases and retrieving files from the
file system
step 5 response once the server has
processed the request it sends an HTTP
response back to the browser this
response includes the requested content
such as the HTML CSS and JavaScript and
any images or other resources required
to display the website
step 6 rendering the browser receives
the response from the server and begins
to render the web page this involves
parsing the HTML and rendering the
layout styling the page with CSS
executing JavaScript and loading any
images or other resources required to
display the page
step 7 user interaction finally the user
can interact with the web page clicking
on links filling out forms and
Performing other actions
these steps happen very quickly often in
a matter of milliseconds but any delay
or bottleneck in any of these steps can
cause the page to load slowly or not at
all leading to a poor user experience to
optimize website performance it's
important to identify and address any
performance issues at each site each
stage of the process
some of the WordPress optimizations have
to happen right on the server so let me
show you how to manage your server in in
motion Central now there will be a
similar process even if you're using
another hosting provider I'll go to
tools then manage server and then we can
see the hostname the IP address and then
we can see that it's currently running
now you can you can see we can use this
to restart or stop the server but what
we want to do is add our SSH key that's
going to allow us to connect to our
server from our local machine SSH keys
are used to securely authenticate with
the server
so we can connect via the command line
interface this is usually the preferred
method for advanced users to manage
their servers since you can quickly make
changes without having to navigate
through a graphical user interface
so to get our SSH key we're gonna have
to generate one so you can open a
terminal on your local computer and then
we can type in SSH key gen or Dash
okay then press enter and it's going to
ask us to enter the file where to save
the key and we'll just press enter again
and uh mine already exists so I'm not
going to override it but uh if you
haven't created before that's what it
would show you
and now we can get it by a copy where
the key is and then I'll do cat and then
just put the location
dot Pub
and then we can see the whole key here
and then I can just copy this key
so I'll go to add SSH key and then I
will just paste in my public key and
then update
and now we will be able to connect to
the server via SSH so I need my IP
address so I'll just copy this IP
address or actually I'll just copy the
hostname here
now go back to a terminal SSH root at
and then the server name or you could
also use the IP address and then we'll
just hit enter here and here we want to
put yes we are sure we want to continue
okay we're logged into the host we're
logged into the server
these tips explain what measures can be
taken with redis my Sequel opcash and
other Technologies to achieve a high
performance server there are many
opportunities to improve performance
I'll focus on Fast storage and emphasize
tuning the caches accessing files from
nvme Storage storing PHP scripts and
opcast and compressing responses with
broadly are all part of a high
performance server I'm going to show you
how to analyze your server performance
and make incremental improvements
services like redis and memcache can
significantly improve WordPress
performance by caching data in memory
and reducing the number of database
calls required to serve content they act
as key value stores that temporarily
hold frequently accessed or
computationally expensive data resulting
in Faster response times and reduce
server load WordPress can be configured
to use redis as an object store by
employing specific plugins such as redis
object cache or W3 Turtle cast so once
redis is installed and configured you
can check the following items to ensure
redis is optimized and operating its
full capacity right now I'm connected to
my server through in motion the server
that has the WordPress installations
installed and already has redis
installed so I can check the redis
memory usage with this command redis CLI
info
memory
and then we get all this information so
if I go scroll up a little bit when the
use memory Peak is close to the max
memory that's shown further down Reddit
may not have enough resources to operate
to its full capacity
in addition redis may be actively
evicting keys from the cache to make
room for new ones this is not ideal and
and key eviction should be avoided if
possible so you can increase the max
memory variable in your redis
configuration to solve the issue and
here are where the configuration files
are
if you make any changes make sure to
restart everything to apply your changes
key eviction key eviction is the process
of removing old and unused data from the
cache to make room for new data this can
be especially problematic for high
traffic websites that rely on redis
caching to improve performance if your
system resources allows for it and the
evicted Keys count is high it's again
recommended to increase max memory the
following command will provide
information about the number of keys and
how many have been evicted
by examining these aspects making the
appropriate adjustments you cannot you
can optimize redis to significantly
enhance your WordPress site's
performance
optimize the database
if object caching like redis is not
available for the WordPress site request
for database content goes straight to
the database if first the database
checks its cache to serve the results
directly if possible and stores it for
future use if caching is unavailable or
not allowed the query proceeds to the
database the database combines cached
and uncached information requesting data
from the operating system the speed of
retrieving the data depends on available
RAM and the storage type with nvme being
the fastest and HDD being the slowest
simple queries return data immediately
to the PHP call while complex queries
requiring temp tables demand more
processing time and can slow down the
website or across server issues under
high traffic
several tuning techniques can improve
performance
you can set the buffer pool size
the buffer pool is the area of memory
that
mariadb uses to cache data and indexes
it's important to configure the buffer
pool size appropriately based on the
amount of available memory and the size
of the database the buffer pool size can
be controlled using the in ODB
underscore buffer underscore pool
underscore size variable you can start
with 128 or 256 megabytes depending on
the total available RAM on your server
check the hit rate and adjust
accordingly to ensure it's working as
expected you can see here where the
configuration files are and always make
sure to restart your services to apply
any of your changes after you after you
configure this
one way to analyze buffer pool
performance is by observing the nodb
underscore buffer underscore pool
underscore way underscore free Status
variable if it's decreasing then you
don't have enough buffer pool or your
your or your flushing isn't occurring
frequently enough in this case you
should set the nodb underscore buffer
underscore pool underscore size variable
higher if your system resources allows
for it
you can also enable query cache query
cache is a feature that stores the
results of frequently executed queries
in memory which can significantly
improve query performance it's
recommended to enable query cache but
it's important to note that it may not
be effective for all workloads the query
Cache can be enabled or disabled using
the query underscore cast underscore
type variable
the SQL Server stores stats about the
query cache query cache is actually
deprecated in my SQL but it still exists
in mariadb
quarter cache has taken a less desirable
place in most MySQL setups because of
the high adoption of multi-core and
multi-server deployments where it can be
a bottleneck for Mario DB it's still
useful for websites and fits well in our
use case where the deployment consists
of a single site on the server
qcash underscore inserts contains the
number of queries added to the query
cache
and qcast underscore hits contains the
number of queries that have made use of
the query cache while qcash underscore
low mem underscore prunes contains the
number of queries that were dropped from
the cache due to lack of memory the
example could indicate a poorly
performing cache more queries have been
added and more queries have been dropped
than have actually been used
you can set in memory table size limits
as previously mentioned complex queries
will cause the SQL Server to create
temporary tables the SQL Server will
attempt to create tables in memory up to
a certain size for performance it's
important to set the Mac size to an
appropriate value to avoid creating on
disk temporary tables
the variables that control that this
Behavior are the TMP underscore table
underscore size and Max underscore Heap
underscore table underscore size you can
compare the number of internal on disk
temporary tables created to the total
number of internal temporary tables
created by comparing the created
underscore TMP underscore disk
underscore tables and created underscore
TMP underscore tables values
you can see if it's necessary to
increase by comparing the status
variables created underscore TMP
underscore disk underscore tables and
created underscore TMP underscore tables
to see how many temporary tables out of
the total created needed to be converted
to disk in this example the SQL server
is not having to create temporary tables
on disk this is considered optimal
another thing you can do is to prune the
WordPress database without intervention
WordPress will store junk and unused
data in the database over time this can
add up causing database bloat and
serious performance lags this includes
items such as post revisions this
include which includes auto save drafts
trashed posts trashed comments comment
spam and tables for plugins and themes
that are no longer active or installed
and transient records
in your
wp-config.php file add or edit the
following setting to limit the number of
post revisions saved to the database
many resources exist on the internet for
dealing with these items monitor
performance it's important to regularly
monitor the performance of Mario DB and
adjust the configurations as necessary
this includes monitoring CPU usage
memory usage disk i o and query
performance use a tool like MySQL tuner
to gain insights on the performance of
the SQL installation or enable slow
query logging to identify long-running
queries
opcast provides significant benefits
when used with PHP fpn when a PHP file
has been previously requested and
there's enough opcash available the
script is already stored in memory this
allows for faster execution as it stands
ready to accept data inputs without
having to reload the file from disk it's
important to maximize opcash hits and
minimize misses and here are where the
configuration files are
if you make any changes make sure to
restart everything to apply your changes
for opcash WordPress plugins are
available they're restricted by auth
Standalone opcast dashboard Pages need
additional security but WordPress
plugins are behind authentication
already PHP provides several built-in
functions to obtain information about
opcash status and configuration like
opcash underscore get underscore status
and opcash underscore get underscore
configuration additionally there are
several web-based monitoring tools to
visualize op cache usage and performance
some popular options include opcast GUI
which is a single file PHP script that
provides a Simple and Clean interface to
monitor op cache usage and performance
and then there's ocp which is a
web-based opcast control panel that
allows you to Monitor and manage opcast
settings in real time opcast status
which is a one-page opcash status page
for the PHP 5.5 up op code cache and
cash tool which allows you to work with
apcu upcash and the file status cast
through the CLI it will connect to a
fast CGI server like PHP fpm and operate
on its cache when reviewing opcash
statistics there are a few key items to
look for and assess opcash hit rate a
hit rate is the percentage of requests
that are being served used using cast op
code instead of parsing and compiling
the scripts Anew this hit rate suggests
opcast requires more memory or resources
to perform its full capacity a hit rate
close to 100 indicates that the cash is
functioning effectively and providing
the desired performance benefits
monitoring the hit rate can help
identify if adjustments to op cache
settings are necessary to improve its
efficiency
the next section will explain how to
adjust the memory allocation for opt
cache
memory consumption
analyzing memory usage involves checking
the amount of memory allocated to the
opt cache and how much of it is being
used
in the output you can see here the
administrator would want to consider
increasing the opcash.memory underscore
consumption to a value higher than 128
megabytes as the cash flow Boolean is
true and free memory is at 8 bytes this
information helps determine if there is
a need to increase or decrease the
memory allocation based on the size and
complexity of your PHP scripts ensuring
an appropriate memory allocation helps
prevent cash evictions and promotes a
more efficient use of server resources
both num cache keys and Max cached keys
are metrics that provide insights into
the number of cast Keys compiled PHP
scripts currently stored in the op cache
the num cache keys and the maximum
number of cache Keys allowed the maxcast
keys by comparing these values you can
identify if the cache is nearing its
capacity or if adjustments are needed to
optimize the cache size if num cache
Keys frequently approaches Max cast Keys
it can be beneficial to increase the
opcash.max accelerated files value to
accommodate more scripts reducing cash
evictions and further improving
performance regularly reviewing these
key items can help you optimize the
opcash configuration leading to improved
website performance and reduced server
resource usage
as previously mentioned in the database
optimization section nvme storage helps
database server performance by providing
significantly faster data access and
reduced latency compared to traditional
Storage Solutions this results in
quicker response times and more
efficient query processing leading to
improved overall server performance disk
IO helps increase performance of all
aspects of your web server and having
nvme speeds usually means that the
database caching in W3 total cast plugin
is not needed and it can have adverse
effects to Performance if enabled nvme
storage improves server performance for
WordPress websites in several ways
faster page load times with its
high-speed data transfer and load
latency in vme storage allows for
quicker access to website files and
assets such as images style sheets and
scripts this leads to faster page load
times and a better use user experience
improved database performance the
benefits of using nvme storage when
processing database queries can be
outlined as follows
when processing queries the database
relies on both cached and uncast MySQL
data requiring interactions with the
operating system to retrieve the
necessary information
if the operating system has ample Ram
the files needed for a query might
already be stored in Ram rather than
only being available on a persistent
storage device finally in cases where
data must be accessed from a storage
device and mvme drive provides
significantly faster data retrieval
compared to a SATA SSD while traditional
hhds are much slower and typically not
used in such scenarios anymore overall
the nvme storage greatly enhances
database query performance due to its
rapid data access capabilities
compressing data server responses with
broadly or gzip can significantly
improve website performance by reducing
the amount of data transferred over the
network this provides a final stage of
optimization on the response being
returned from the origin server on
average gzip compression can reduce the
size of web content by 60 to 70 percent
while broadly tends to provide even
better compression Rate rates often
reducing content size by 70 to 80
percent enabling broadly compression
with within nginx is accomplished
through the use of the broadly nginx
module the module can be compiled and
installed alongside nginx and loaded
dynamically analyze a server response
for compression to determine if a
request response was compressed with
broadly or gzip compression you can use
Chrome or Firefox developer tools to to
review the content encoding headers
so you can follow these steps open the
developer Tools in your browser we'll
click on the network tab in the
developer tools
refresh the webpage or initiate the
action you want to analyze this will
populate the network panel with a list
of requests made by the browser
then we'll find the request we're
interested in such as the main document
request or a specific resource like a
CSS or JavaScript file we'll click on
the request to open the detailed View
and the detailed view we'll look for the
headers tab this should be the default
tab in both browsers scroll down to the
response headers section
then we'll check the value of the
content encoding header if this response
is compressed with gzip it will display
gzip and if it's compressed with broadly
it will display BR if the header is
absent or has a different value the
response is not compressed using either
of these algorithms by examining the
content encoding header in the developer
tools you can quickly determine if a
request response was compressed with
broadly or gzip
Syrian requests from the nginx cat can
result in significant performance
improvements as it eliminates the need
for the request to Traverse the entire
stack and access the backend services
this can lead to reduced processing
times and improved response times
resulting in a better user experience
according to benchmarks serving requests
from the nginx Cache can result in a 90
reduction in response times compared to
requests that Traverse the entire stack
this is due to the cash mechanism's
ability to serve requests directly from
memory or disk reducing the time taken
to process the request furthermore
serving requests from the nginx Cache
can significantly reduce server load and
improve scalability by reducing the
number of requests that must be handled
by back-end services like PHP fpm or
MySQL the server can handle more
requests concurrently leading to
improved performance and faster response
times this is a Sim Council for a high
traffic website the ultrastack nginx
configuration adds an X proxy cache HTTP
header to responses and the Upstream
cache status to nginx access log entries
the following through techniques
explained how to identify whether the
page being received is a cast version
served by nginx
we can use Curl we can make a simple get
request to the URL in question and use
grip to check the X proxy cache header
also we can use Chrome Dev tools you can
use F12 or the other shortcut to bring
up the devtools window then click the
network tab click the box that says
disable cache which will bypass Chrome's
internal cache then reload the page to
capture all of the network information
not disabling Chrome's cache will allow
you to see 304 not modified responses
for static assets which shows how the
client-side cache is working
the following are the possible values
for Upstream cache status
miss the response was not found in the
cache and so is fetched from An Origin
server the response might then have been
cached bypass the response was fets from
the origin server instead of fetched
from the cast because the response
matched a proxy cash bypass directive
expired the entry in the cache has
expired the response contains fresh
content from the origin server still the
content is stale because the ordinance
server is not responding correctly and
proxycash used stale was configured
updating the content is stale because
the entry is currently being updated in
response to a previous request and proxy
cash you stale updating is configured
revalidated the proxycash revalidate
directive was enabled and index verified
that the current cache content was still
valid
hit the response contains valid fresh
content front direct from the cache
another technique to explain how to
identify whether the page being received
is the cast version served by nginx is
using the nginx access log you connect
to the server using SSH and read the
access log with a tail or a cat
the value assigned to UCS or the
Upstream cache status will be one of the
cache statuses we talked about before
using Central's managed server tools
here's how you would enable nginx proxy
cache on your site
with nginx proxy cast configured you you
may use the ultra stack utilities to
determine the cash hit rates for all
requests to nginx
while this is a tool specific to
in-motion hosting the information can be
retrieved using the third-party nginx
module VTS so in summary using nginx
proxycast will help drive performance
for a high traffic websites
while the exact amount depends on the
specific workload of the website a
minimum of four gigabytes and two vcpu
cores is recommended when bits marking
your resource needs on a high traffic
website in a high performance server
running MySQL redis PHP fpm Apache and
nginx having enough RAM is critical to
allow each surface's caching techniques
to work at their full potential these
services use Ram to Cache frequently
accessed data and reduce the time taken
to retrieve it from disk or other
storage devices if the server does not
have enough RAM the caching will not be
as effective leading to longer
processing times and slower website
performance for instance MySQL uses the
nodb buffer pool to cast frequently
Access Data from the database and redis
uses memory to store frequently accessed
data and key value pairs PHP fpm uses
opcafs to Cache PHP scripts and engine X
uses Ram to Cache frequently requested
web pages and assets if the server does
not have sufficient Ram these caching
techniques will not be as effective and
the server May resort to swapping data
in and out of slower storage devices
leading to a slower response times and
reduced server capacity swap usage to
determine if a Linux server is swapping
you can use the free command to view the
system's memory usage if the swap value
is greater than zero it indicates that
the server is currently using swap space
to store data in memory Additionally you
can use the VM stat command to monitor
the amount of swapping activity
occurring on the server with the SI and
the so values indicating the amount of
memory being swapped in and out
respectively this example does not use
Swap and is not swapping
um oom kills to determine if a Linux
server is experiencing
um oh om or out of memory kills you can
check the system logs for messages
related to um events on most Linux
distributions the system log file is
located at vars log slash messages or
vars slash log syslog to view oom
related messages you can search for the
keyword oom using the grep command
if
um or oom events are occurring you'll
see entries that indicate which process
or application was killed by the oom
killer Additionally you can use tools
like dmesg and journal control to view
kernel messages related to um events by
having enough RAM on the server each
service can utilize caching techniques
to their fullest extent resulting in
Faster processing time reduced disk
usage and an overall better user
experience
there's a plug-in that's super helpful
when it comes to optimizing WordPress
sites let me show you how to install it
really easily within motion but you can
also install it basically with any
WordPress installation so we'll go to
optimize and then WordPress we have the
W3 total cache now you can see that it
improves SEO and users and the user
experience of your site by increasing
website performance reducing load times
via features like content delivery
Network integration and the latest best
practices
so basically I'm just going to click
here and W3 total cash is one of the
most popular ways to optimize and manage
the cash for your WordPress site
so and this is going to result in Faster
load times and less strain on your
server which is definitely going to help
with SEO you can also enable this within
the WordPress dashboard if you don't
have in motion Central and I'll show you
that how to do that in a second right
now I'm going to click on setup guide
and this is going to help you set up
things but we're going to configure on
our own so I'll skip this setup guide so
before we do that I'm going to show you
how you would install this with just
WordPress if you don't have the in
motion settings so we just go to plugins
and then add new and then you just
search for W3
total cash
so here is where you would install it
and activate it but we already have
installed and activated
so I'm going to go back to this
performance tab here
that's the W3 total cast Tab and before
I go through setting it up let me just
give you a little more context
so by default WordPress is a dynamic CMS
that means for every visitor request
that WordPress has to process it must
first connect to the database to see if
the requested page even exists
in a lot of cases this might not be
problematic on a site that just doesn't
receive much traffic however a sudden
surge in traffic caused by search engine
Bots or just a general increase in
normal traffic can quickly cause your
WordPress site to use up a lot of CPU
resources from the server while trying
to fulfill needless duplicate requests
again and again
you can counter this increase in CPU
usage by implementing a caching plug-in
what these do is cache the first
visitor's request of a new page to a
plain HTML file on the server then when
another visitor comes through the and
requests the same page so long as the
page wasn't updated in your admin
section or updated by comment the cast
HTML page will be served this can
greatly reduce CPU usage of your
WordPress site very easily as an example
let's say you had 100 views of your
front page without caching that would
require the same database query to have
to run 100 times and every time it's
just getting back to the exact same data
anyway
with the caching plugin only the first
user would have the database query run
to generate the cast HTML file then the
next 99 visitors would get that cast
HTML serve to them right away without
having to wait for any database activity
to complete this is basically always a
win-win because your visitors don't have
to wait as long for your pages to load
and you're reducing the impact of
wordpress's requests on the server's
performance now I do want to note that
database caching is not recommended for
shared hosting as the process is
dependent on the disk speed of the
server so due to the nature of shared
system resources disk speed may be
limited and so database caching May
adversely affect the performance of the
site really what you want to do is
experiment with different casting
techniques to see which one works best
for your site so now let's see how to
set up the W3 total casting plugin I'm
going to go to the general settings here
okay and then I'm going to make sure
that the page cache is enabled and then
for all these settings we're just gonna
want to click
um either save all settings or save
settings and purchase caches after you
update the settings one thing to keep in
mind is that you never want to use both
nginx page caching and total cash that
would slow things down and would cause
some conflicts with the caching so you
just basically just want to use one or
the other another good feature to use is
the Minify you can see this is going to
reduce the load Time by decreasing the
size and number of CSS and JavaScript
files so it's it's gonna make things
load a lot quicker if you enable the
Minify if if you are enabling Minify
you're going to want to make sure to
check your WordPress site to make sure
the site looks normal if you see
problems then you can disable the
minification
and this is where you can use opcast to
validate timestamps so it will request
the cast with the latest version
and then you see the database cache it
caching it caches the database objects
and this decreases the response time of
the site so it doesn't have to load from
the database every time
we're not we have it disabled because
it's best if object caching is not
possible but in our case we're going to
use object caching then you also have
the browser cache
and you can enable or disable a CDN
and when you're choosing a CDN you're
going to have to choose the basically
the CDN provider what which CDN you're
going to use
I'm actually going to disable this
because for a CDN you're going to have
to sign up for a CDN account and make
sure not to click the CD in button if
you don't have a CDN that could actually
mess some things up for your site okay
I'm going to save this and then we'll go
over to
the pagecast tab
so we're going to just check the
settings on this page we're going to we
want to make sure we cast the front page
cast the feeds cast SSL we don't want to
cast the Uris we want to Cache the 404
don't cast page for logged in users
don't cast page for the following user
role just the administrator role so
we're just going to use all these
default settings and this is just going
to make sure we cache the page we want
to cache and don't cache the pages we
don't want to Cache so I'll just save
settings and Purge caches
so now I'm going to go to the website
I'll just go to visit site here
and I will go to view page source and
then if I go all the way down to the
bottom I should see something
yep performance optimized by W3 total
cash
so now I know that it's you it's working
correctly and it's installed correctly
so I'm back over on the toolcast setting
page I want to talk about cleaning your
WordPress cache this is something you
may need to do from time to time when
using a caching plugin to speed up
WordPress if you make changes to your
WordPress site and don't see the changes
when visit when visiting the updated
page you may need to clear your cache
this is because the caching plugin could
still be showing the cached version of
your page so to force WordPress to show
your most recent changes right away you
can delete the cache so basically just
go to the the main settings page and
then we can click empty all caches just
like that
all caches successfully emptied
now let's talk about browser caching and
some implementation techniques
e-tags the e-tag HTTP response header is
one that web servers and browsers use to
determine whether a resource in the
browser's local cache matches the one in
the origin server
when a user revisits its site one of two
things happen it displays content to the
user in the browser if it's within the
allowable cache refresh time the time to
live
if content is out of its Cash Time TTL
expired then
if it has an e-tag then it will need to
send an e-tag to the resolved URL to see
if it needs to refresh
then if it gets the matching e-tag then
it will keep the content it has no new
downloading of content and set the
existing contents TTL into the future
which makes it a viable cast content for
the TTL and if it gets a different e-tag
then it will it will trigger a fresh
download of the new content
if it does not have an e-tag then it
will send a request out to get the
potentially new content and it will
download that content regardless of
whether it really is new or not
it's important to note that the e-tag
request and response is much much
smaller than a download of content as
most websites do not change change
between ttls the ttls need to be low
just in case the site does change
therefore the eteg process is much more
efficient than ttls by themselves
so how do you check if your server
response is using e-tags well you open
the developer Tools in your browser
using your the shortcut key or you can
right click on the web page and click
inspect then click on the network tab in
the developer tools
next refresh the web page or initiate
the action you want to analyze this will
populate the network panel with a list
of requests made by the browser
next locate a specific resource like a
CSS or JavaScript file click on the
request to open the detailed View
in the detailed view look for the
headers tab
then scroll down to the response header
section for the selected file and check
for the presence of an e-tag
how to configure etags in W3 total cache
in your WordPress admin dashboard
navigate the performance browser cache
we'll scroll down to the general section
check the box next to the set entity tag
e-tag setting on the same page using the
same method you can also enable or
disable etags for specific files types
including CSS and JS HTML and XML media
and other files
finally press the save settings and
Purge caches button within each
respective setting box to save and apply
the the caching changes immediately
time to live
the time to live value is the time that
an object is stored in a caching system
before it's deleted or refreshed in the
context of cdns TDL typically refers to
the content caching which is the process
of storing a copy of your website
resources on CDM proxies to improve page
load speed and reduce origin server
bandwidth consumption tdls are used for
caching purposes and the value is stored
in seconds if the TDL value is set to a
low number like 3 600 seconds the data
will be stored in the cast for one hour
after one hour a new version of the data
needs to be retrieved if the TDL value
is set to a high number like 86 400
seconds the data will be stored in the
cast for 24 hours High TDL values cache
your data longer and lessen the
frequency for retrieving new data this
gives your website a performance boost
by reducing the server's load which
improves the user's experience let's
look at how to set TTL policies in W3
total cash
you can make some limited changes to the
TTL by going to page cache and then you
scroll all the way down to Advanced
here's the advanced section and then we
can update the garbage collection
interval which is how frequently the
expired cache data is removed and then
also the comment cookie lifetime this is
going to reduce the default TTL for
Comic cookies
and it's going to reduce the number of
authenticated user traffic
let's talk about the HTTP cache control
headers
so here are the different ones there's
cache control max age the max age
directive specifies the maximum number
of times that a resource may be cast by
a client or a proxy server after
expiring a browser must refresh refresh
its version of the resource by sending
another request to a server
cast control max age 3600 means that the
return resource is valid for one hour
after which the browser has to request a
new version
cast control no cash the no cash
directive tells a browser or a casting
server not to use the cast version of a
resource and to request a new version of
the resource from the origin server
cast control no store the no store
directive tells browsers to never store
a copy of the resource and not to keep
it in the cache this setting is usually
used for sensitive information like
credit card numbers and ensures PCI
compliance by not storing this type of
data in the cache
cast control public the public response
directive indicates that a resort
resource can be cached by any cache this
directive is useful for resources that
change and frequently and when the
resource is intended for public
consumption
cash control private the private
response directive indicates that a
resource is user specific it can still
be cast but only on a client device for
example a web page response marked as
private can be cast by a browser but not
a Content delivery Network now let's see
how to set ATP cast control headers in
W3 total cache
so to set up the cast control headers in
W3 Turtle cache you go to the
browsercast performance browser cache
and then we are going to determine what
are the cast control policies will be
for some different files
so I can scroll down
to the CSS and JavaScript section
and then we'll set the cast control
header
now I'll select the cast control policy
and I'll just select this one cache with
max age
and then you can do the same thing for
HTML and XML we can set the cast control
header and choose the policy and then
for the median other files we can set
the ks control header and set the policy
and then you always want to make sure to
save changes and Purge caches
cash busting cash busting is a technique
used to force a browser or caching
service to retrieve a new version of a
resource rather than using the cast
version one way to do this is by using
query parameters such as a timestamp or
a version number in the URL of the
resource for example instead of
requesting resource at the URL
example.com styles.css a cash busting
URL would look like example.com
style.css and then get the version one
two three four where V equals one two
three four is the query parameter this
query parameter can be a timestamp or a
version number and will be ignored by
the server but it will force the browser
or caching server to treat the request
as a new request rather than using the
cast version of the resource this
technique is often used for static
resources like like styleship scripts or
images that are intended to be cast but
they may not be needed to be updated
frequently by appending a query
parameter to the URL a new version of
the resource will be retrieved each time
the query parameter changes this
technique is commonly used to ensure
that the client gets the latest version
of the resources after they're updated
to the on the server side
to enable cash busting and W3 Turtle
cache we'll go to the performance and
the the browser cache section and then
we just have to go to
um prevent caching of objects after
settings change
this will add a random string at the end
of static asset urls
cache storage is a finite resource so
every bit of storage performance matters
caching at proxy servers is one of the
ways to reduce the response time
perceived by web users you have to
choose between ease of use versus
complicated configurations versus your
needs you have to look at the CDN level
Edge caching the server nginx proxy
cache the WordPress plugins application
Level caching what do you have now
what's your budget cdns can be expensive
whereas your audience in relation to
your server what do we want to guide the
user to do
cast replacement algorithms play a
central role in reducing response Times
by selecting specific websites assets
for caching so that a given performance
metric is maximized they do this by
deciding which objects can stay and
which objects should be you evicted the
next time the website is accessed the
different policies are released recently
used this replaces the cache line that
has been in the casa longus with no
references to it then first in first out
replaces the cast line that has been in
the cast the longest
least frequently used replaces a cache
line that has experienced the fewest
references or random pick a line at
random from the candidate lines
page caching refers to caching the
content of a whole page on the server
side later when the same page is
requested again its content will be
served from the cache instead of
regenerating it from scratch a page from
a WordPress website contains Dynamic
content PHP scripts JavaScript and SQL
queries executing this Dynamic content
is very resource heavy and takes a lot
of time page caching allows for forming
a part of the website and to static HTML
with page cache enabled website content
displays faster for a visitor with less
load on the server it's one of the most
efficient ways to improve your website
performance
object caching is the process that
involves storing database queries to
serve a specific piece of data on the
subsequent server request as a result
there will be fewer queries sent to the
database and the result is your website
will load much faster WordPress object
cache the idea of an object cache is
that WordPress core themes and plugins
May store some data that is frequently
accessed and readily changed in the
object store
this is so these objects will not have
to be retrieved and processed on each
request
WP object cache is WordPress is class
for caching data and by default the
optic cache is non-persistent this means
that data stored in the cache resides in
memory only and only for the duration of
the request cache data will not be
stored persistently across page loads
unless you install a persistent caching
plugin ultimately object caching will
reduce the total number of database
queries required for each page load when
the CPU does not have to rebuild this
box of data your response time will
decrease
once the server and database have been
tuned for performance the next step is
to ensure the application is optimized
for performance this can be done by
leveraging techniques designed to
deliver assets much more efficiently or
removing any unnecessary data from them
resulting in Faster transfers the
following are some of the most effective
techniques you can use when it comes to
optimizing your WordPress site for Speed
but it's not an exhaustive list when
focusing on page and website performance
there are some essential tasks you can
complete to help you achieve the
performance results you're looking for
these tasks include configuring caching
following best practices for elements
that can introduce layout shifts and
adjusting your assets to ensure they are
configured for the fastest possible
delivery to your visitors
one page caching WordPress is a dynamic
program by default so the easiest way to
speed things up is to create a static
version of your website pages and use
redirects to serve those cast files
instead of calculating the result again
with PHP and MySQL this Cache can be
stored on the disk in the server's Ram
or if you're using a CDN on a point of
presence or Edge server if you're
storing the page cache on the web server
then it's recommended to use disk
enhanced storage so the web server
redirects can serve the cache prior to
the request reaching PHP essentially
making the site load faster by using
these static files instead of recreating
them with queries and calculations
storing page cache on a CDN at the edge
is a practice known as full site
delivery or acceleration where the
website is served by sending a cast
version of the website from a geographic
location near the visitor as opposed to
the request reaching out to the origin
server where the data lives this removes
location and induced this removes
location introduced latency from the
equation making websites much faster for
all of your visitors two object caching
with redis by default the object cache
in WordPress is not persistent this
means that data stored in the cache
resides in memory for the duration of
the request and is often removed after
the response is delivered to store these
cast objects for reuse you can use a
plugin that connects WordPress the
WordPress cast to redis ram-based
service that is used for persistent
object storage W3 Turtle cast will allow
you to use object casting with red
restore the data as keys in the web
server's memory which allows for
retrieval of the data to happen much
faster than the WordPress method which
castes those objects to the options
table in the database by default
three leveraging common ux patterns when
adding elements such as fonts carousels
banners to your website you want to
ensure that you are following best
practices these types of elements can
have a negative impact on core web
vitals if not implemented correctly
great example of this is not explicitly
setting proper placeholders or
dimensions for images videos iframes or
other similar embedded content
throughout your page when the content is
loaded this can cause layout shift and
core web vitals has very specific
metrics as a moving page can create a
bad user experience for your visitor
loading custom fonts on your website is
another example where things can go
wrong adding them incorrectly can delay
the text rendering or even cause layout
shifts typically your browser will delay
displaying text until the font is loaded
which can also impact your FCP or LCP if
the text does load prior to your web
font and their different sizes layout
shifts will occur and directly impact
your CLS score for a minification When
developing a website most programmers
tend to use spacing and comments to make
code readable for both themselves and
others minification is a technique used
to reduce load times on a website by
removing unnecessary characters and
comments from the code for faster
delivery and rendering this technique
can be used on HTML CSS and JavaScript
files and can dramatically improve your
site's performance
to Minify your assets with W3 total cash
you'll need to enable it in general
settings there's an automatic mode which
attempts to handle the heavy lifting for
you but if you have issues with it
you'll need to enable manual mode and
add the assets you wish to be minified
yourself under the Minify page
there is the help wizard to for setting
up Minify which you can use to specify
the template to use when loading the
asset
5 concatenation the term concatenation
refers to the action of linking things
together in a series in the context of a
website performance this means combining
multiple CSS and JavaScript files into a
few files to deliver the assets the
browser needs faster with less requests
in W3 total cash concatening files is an
option in general settings under Minify
checking the Box will allow you to
combine the asset files into one of
three different files in the Dom one in
the head one in the body or one at the
footer before closing the document six
eliminate render blocking resources
render blocking resources is essentially
coding your website files usually CSS
and JavaScript that prevents a web page
from loading quickly to ensure your site
loads as efficiently as possible you can
specify attributes that tell the browser
how to download the code in relation to
the other site assets
when concatenating and minifying files
using W3 total cache you'll also have
the option of embedding them before the
the close of the document's head tag or
after the body tag to improve
performance you have the option of
setting Rel attributes for the assets
such as async or defer which will tell
the browser when and how to load the
file the Minify wizard in total cache
will allow you to specify which JS and
CSS files load by template allowing you
to have to have fine-tuned control over
which assets load when and where
seven pre-connect and prefetched DNS
hints if your site is using multiple
third-party scripts the location those
scripts are hosted on will be considered
a cross-origin domain that third-party
domain will need to be resolved to an IP
address for the browser to download the
file and complete the request the time
it takes for this DNS resolution to take
place can introduce latency into the
page load and using preconnect and
prefetch we'll instruct the browser to
handle this prior to fetching the asset
this can help remove the latency
introduced by resolving a large number
of DNS requests for assets in the
background using DNS prefetch and
pre-connect links will help your page
load faster by performing these
operations for later use the DNS
prefetch will do a DNS lookup while
pre-connect will establish the
connection to the server this connection
established will also include a TLS
handshake if served over https
the pre-connect hint should be used
sparingly and only for the most critical
assets being used in the viewport during
the initial page load for non-critical
assets using only the DNS prefetch hint
is recommended
8. image optimization image optimization
refers to the practice of a website
delivering the highest quality image
with the right format
with the right format resolution and
dimensions for the device and viewport
accessing them this is done with the
intent of keeping the file size as small
as possible there are several layers
when dealing with optimizing your images
including removing metadata converting
to a different format resizing and lazy
loading one of the ways to reduce an
image's file size is to remove any
metadata attached to the file the static
can include information about the camera
used to take the picture GPS coordinates
the file's owners comments a thumbnail
and more there are several types of
metadata that can be added to the images
including exif iptc XMP removing this
data will help to decrease the file size
of the image an added benefit is that
removing metadata keeps these details
from being publicly shared
webp is a compression format for images
developed by Google when optimizing your
images for Speed using webp is the
recommended format for websites most
modern browsers now support the webp
image format there are many WordPress
plugins that offer this type of image
conversion and most even assists with
redirects to automate the process and a
fallback option in case the browser does
not support the webp format W3 total
cache has a service for conversion of
images and redirects under media library
when image service extension is
activated Dynamic image resizing when
different devices are used to access
your web page the image size needed will
vary depending on the visitor's viewport
Dynamic image sizes can be used to make
each of these devices load the image
with a size tailored specifically to the
viewport where the site is being
rendered a great example of this would
be the hero image on your website while
a desktop would likely need the full
size version of the web of the image the
narrow viewport of a mobile device life
may only need an image that is 20 of
that size providing the browser with the
smaller size would reduce the time it
needs to download the file and display
it there are many WordPress plugins and
CDM providers that offer Dynamic
resizing for images the solution you
choose could be based on your audience
if your visitors are mostly local and
your traffic's not high volume a cdn's
cost for this service May outweigh the
benefits to you so using a WordPress
plugin may be your best option
nine lazy loading images and other
embeds lazy loading is the practice of
identifying non-critical assets and
ensuring they only load later as needed
to render the page in the browser in the
context of images lazy loading is
usually based on a user interaction such
as scrolling and loads images needed as
the user gets near them lazy loading
allows the first render to happen faster
as instructs the browser to only load
the critical resources needed to display
what is being rendered in the viewport
then as you scroll the application can
detect when resources are needed and
initialize the download W3 tool cache
offers lazy loading for images finally
using image facades for interactive
elements one of the biggest issues
authors run across is having multiple
video embeds from providers such as
YouTube or Vimeo loading these videos
will force your site to do the DNS
lookups make connections to these
third-party servers in the background
and download the elements needed to
render the content providing an image
that is stored from your site's domain
as an interaction point to trigger
loading these types of content embeds
can save you precious time rendering
your web page it also saves a user from
downloading JavaScript and CSS for an
element they're not going to use as the
video does not render unless the user
specifically clicks on the image anchor
link to trigger it this is also true for
other interactive elements such as chat
embeds or other interactive elements
that are not hosted on your server and
are being served to your visitor from a
remote service
okay now that we've done some
optimization to our WordPress page let's
enter the WordPress URL on the page
speed insight and analyze it again
and we can see the numbers
are better our performance is up
and our performance up on mobile and our
performance is up on desktop this was a
basic overview for configuring your
performance and there are additional
ways to drill down into your
configuration when aiming for higher
scores a great example of this is using
custom page templates for your most
visited and important landing pages and
using the Minify help wizard to only
load the critical CSS and JavaScript
assets on those pages if they're needed
some plugins like contact forms can load
their resources on all pages even if
there's not a contact form embedded
we've reached the end of the course
you've learned about key metrics
imported to website performance and
you've learned a bunch of things you can
do to optimize the performance of your
website thanks for watching